marc marquez games ma agli occhi storti
io sono io store house versione 1.3 bene
a tutti ragazzi bene tutti ragazzi e
bella tutti ragazzi siamo su un house
che è un gioco horror che avete
consigliato della community dischord un
applauso omega che sia accorto di questo
piccolo capolavoro speriamo lo sia che
un horror pixelato su steam e vi ricordo
che potete consigliarmi giochi sul
discorso della community controllo di
descrizione e magari gioco colori non
siate tipo questo se la ragazza in
questione si sveglia vestito wake up
so che c'è giorno
ecco qua non erano gli occhi guerriera
un pixel fatto male buongiorno non so
niente però non rom pixelato e mi dicono
che che merita va bene io ci credo ci
sono delle rane nella tv ania gold shift
su sprint va bene sono cagato cosa fai
sorella sempre che tu sia mia sorella
non so forse tu sei mia madre java ma
che poi in capi da un boia bar di slow
many more non preoccuparti più di questa
distanza va bene posso fare colazione
mamma dopo che fitto di sbarrare la
porta mi auricola perfetto non ho molto
appetito ma farò qualcosa per te grazie
c'è il gatto
ciao gatto è cosa mi aspettavo che
diffonde un bel piano dal mio gatto
chosen presi al di sotto di a molte
porte che casa astraeva pevak e casa è
solo latte posso versare il latte non so
dove per terra perfetto mi sembra
corretto ma 9 stato le latte sulla
pozzanghera tanto bagnato per bagnato
ecco perché la fiducia
[Musica]
mi dissocio
mi dissocio facciamo meno della mamma e
prendiamo i seguici che la mamma ci ha
preparato sono caduto su mia mamma morta
gatto vieni gatto è morta mia ma è ovvio
che c'è una chiave qualche non so per
quale motivo detto vieni qua sì ma che
cassino sto succedere di vista casa va
bene anche lo sto gioco normale giocare
non so cosa forse mi sono cagato nelle
mutande va bene mamma cosa succede mamma
cosa fai aiuto si sposta tutto qua spero
per te e vabbè qualche gioco è un
attimino un po cruda devo proprio
ripartire all'inizio ma cosa sa che lì
si riparte proprio ma dai
quindi io devo interagire in tempo per
ora che adesso ho iniziato un elevata
migliori fare i semplici a non c'è mia
madre se ci fate caso adesso vediamo
non c'è niente ok ora lo ammazzo prima
prendo questo la faccio cadere prima che
arrivi tu e io se riesco la faccio
cascare 4 ammazzo io prima eccola qua
priva tutto a tempo
no il caricato sta leccando latte e per
mia madre è quello dei morì ma no dammi
la chiave gatto
no non lo prendo potevo prendere la
chiave per aprire con la porta prima che
mia madre morisse quindi io cercherei un
modo per assorbire a vedi che c'è
qualcosa come palla da bowling sotto par
la pesca troppo abile in testa c'è mia
sorella è morto il gatto grazie e
sorella non andrà olio queste mura va
bene non andare nel pianoforte che mori
e vabbè io ci ho provato
poi c'e della roba space tour e gol dai
baci un secchio ha forse sentito devo
prendere prima casa
porca [ __ ] un topo enorme nel gigante
cosa succede sto gioco va beh
forse io devo prendere il secchio e
metterli per raccogliere l'acqua prima
che mia madre moya del mentre no nel
mentre magari vado a disturbare mia
sorella che è successo a gatto nel
mentre vado a evitare che mia sorella si
sieda sul piano coach e questa cosa devo
fare immagine o il secchio secchio lo
devo bocciare qua poi c'è il secchio
troppo no ecco quanto vecchio trovato
che perfetta le sue mia madre non
dovrebbe morire io ho la chiave questo
che cacchio è un ascia non è qui porco
del demonio dove caso dei mia mamma in
là che fa la colazione vedo se riesco a
prendere lascia e smerciare strafare
wind jet set cala è spaccati ho rotto il
vaso c'è un proiettile
ok spengono sorella non andavano ne
andare male è andata che lo fa è messo
alla porta tac tac tac
spero che mia mamma di tutto questo non
sia morta perché effettivamente io ho
messo l'eroe che devo fare qui pick up
preso qualcosa un fucile o anche il
proiettile item quindi funziona posso
sparare a qualcuno non so chi non ha
ancora capito come si schiacciano i
tassi piuttosto del vino penso che il
proiettile funzioni in automatico c'è
una botta da qua c'è un apporto di
sangue bravissimo mamma bravissimo
bravissimo non è morta sorella e c'è da
mangiare di là va bene mangio io no il
gatto andato a vedere faccio mangio io
mamma che mia sorella è morta
posso prendere i sandwich e usarlo da
qualche parte caccia vacca
no troppo da qualche perché non so
effettivamente cosa serva sanguis
aspetto che esca mia sorella liszt spara
in faccia fortissimo il tappeto roma tre
che regoli a ragazzi è orribile credo
che si possa finire veramente in fretta
se tu sapessi cosa fare prima che non si
sa con doo si capisce cosa fare
magari suggeritemi anche nei commenti
laga comunque tutto sto casino in tutto
sto casino effettivamente dal quadro con
la parola ormai la sua memoria
il tutto sto casino non sono ancora
riuscito in tre nella botola e pensa sì
importante allora prendo questo sveglio
il gatto cioè se giocate giuste perché
ho fatto che qua
ok adesso devo prendere lascia lascia è
fondamentale ragazzi secondo me
non sia proprio la portali di secchio
naio prendi qua adesso preferisco qua
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia usain bolt
perfetto perfetto proprio lui ce l'ho
fatta
allora è entro metto il secchio e fin
qua e la prassi e l'abbiamo capita ok
una volta che ho messo sta roba vado a
lasciare la porta con lascia la smash
che spinga spinga veloce
ok tutto la palla da bowling a sto punto
sulla porta perché non mi fa entrare
ragazzi se non funziona la striscia la
swing scusami stasera dell'aprile i
catodi c'è qualcosa che non capisco il
suo gioco c'è qualcosa di veramente
strano allora voi è che c'è un morto ma
che mamma ma cosa fai
c'è uno sling shot perché non ho capito
cosa sia provato librarmi il tappeto
ce l'ho fatta mamma mia che giocatore
aiuto c'è uno li entrò in camera mia c'è
la bambola che parla dei dvd home su
papa tornerà a casa mi trovi porterai ma
poi a casa papa ma e papà e sale vivo
cioè nel senso è un mostro papa
[Musica]
ragazzi io veramente non so però ho
provate tutte
raga fatemi sapere nei commenti fare un
altro trai sicuro e bellissimo solo che
non si capisce una sega che è bello non
mi piace anche l'istituto tastiera so
che vi risiede nell aria
[Musica]